[Musique]
cérémonie traditionnelle pour célébrer
l'esprit ancestral des Syria
les villageois dansent aussi pour leur
renaissance culturelle obtenue après des
années de lutte judiciaire la petite
nation autochtone siraya vient tout
juste d'être reconnu par le gouvernement
taïwanais
le repas offert au Dieu et partager en
famille prend une toute autre
signification cette fois-ci
il s'agit de transmettre fièrement
l'héritage de la nation aux enfants
malgré toutes les embûches taux de
chômage élevé et inégalité sociale les
problèmes de communauté autochtones de
Taïwan sont semblables à celle du Canada
l'essor et la vitalité de ces petites
communautés est devenu une priorité
récemment à Taïwan
arrivé au pouvoir en 2016 la présidente
side a présenté ses excuses aux nations
autochtones qui représentent deux et
demi pour cent de la population une
démarche de pardon pour les injustices
commises inspirés à l'époque par celles
du gouvernement canadien
les conclusions et les appels au
changement de la Commission de vérité et
de réconciliation du Canada guide
également le gouvernement taïwanais
explique le ministre les documents ont
été traduits dans chacune des 16 langues
autochtones de Taïwan
la grande priorité en la matière à
Taïwan a été la revitalisation de ces
langues bannies pendant près de 60 ans
de règne autocratique une génération
entière a été forcée d'ignorée et
d'oublier ses origines
moi-même été puni lorsque j'étais
étudiant pour avoir simplement
osé parler dans ma langue maternelle
explique-t-il des cours de langue
autochtones sont offertes de la
maternelle depuis quelques années à
Taïwan
s'est donné pour mission de faire
connaître sa culture et sa réalité grâce
à sa musique son public est composé à
90% d'un non autochtone qui connaissent
souvent mal l'histoire de Taïwan
plus de la moitié des autochtones de
Taïwan vivent maintenant enlever les non
plus cette culture ancestrale
explique-t-il c'est donc encore plus
important de transmettre notre héritage
si la persévérance et la résistance des
sirayas ont été récompensés le combat
pour la création d'emplois pour les
autochtones dans leur territoire
ancestraux continuera d'être une
priorité
le gouvernement est déjà avec la
reconnaissance que nous avons obtenu
dit-elle
malgré tout le travail qui reste à
accomplir pour réparer les lourdes
injustices chaque pas vers l'avant est
célébré comme une grande victoire à
Taïwan